aujourd'hui on va parler du galaxy s
8 le tout nouveau téléphone de samsung
le tout nouveau téléphone qui va sortir
dans quelques temps il ya une keynote
qui va avoir lieu le 29 mars prochain
très très très prochainement et on saura
tout sur ce nouveau samsung galaxy et
suite
sauf que en attendant il ya plein
d'infos qui ont fuité on parle même plus
de rumeurs on parle d'un faux quasi
avéré sur ce que va être le futur galaxy
et suites et le galaxy et suit plus
et justement je donnais quelles sont ces
infos te dire d'où elles viennent
et quelles vont être les ré nouveauté de
ce samsung galaxy s 8
avant toute chose il faut vraiment dire
que 2010 est ça va être l'année du
renouveau pour la téléphonie mobile déjà
samsung avec son galaxy s chute qui
veulent vraiment faire très très fort et
puis je dirais proposer plein de
nouvelles fonctionnalités et renouveler
un petit peu cette gamme de galaxies qui
est calme le haut de gamme de la
téléphonie mobile chez samsung est en
face de ça il ya apple que la famine qui
note un joint ou d'ici quelques mois
même boire quelques jours entre peut se
compter comme ça pour présenter la
version des dix ans d'une manif on avait
parlé à quelques temps j'ai fait une
vidéo tient pas c'est d'ailleurs un
petit coup d'oeil
cette vidéo annonce un peu les rumeurs
et les grandes tendances qui était en
train de se dessiner pour cette nouvelle
version de l'iphone l'iphone 8 qu'on
appelle aussi l'iphone 10 avec une croix
10 pour les dix ans donc on a d'un côté
ce que pourrait être un fameux iphone 8
est ce que vous risquez d'être aussi
très très très probablement le samsung
galaxy et suite et ce qui est quand même
relativement d'un gars tu verras
regardant cette vidéo tu te feras ton
idée une toque tora où celle ci à nantes
hier c'est que en réalité ce qu'on
attend du samsung galaxy s suite et de
l'iphone 8
ben c'est sensiblement la même chose
donc quelles vont être les nouvelles
surprises qu'elle - quelle nouveauté
qu'est ce qui va nous surprendre
il va y avoir plein de points
aujourd'hui qu'on ne connaît pas encore
on a déjà les grands pendant qu'on sait
ce qui va se passer et je te dire dans
quelques instants les nouveautés qui
soient effectivement les plus probables
pour ce samsung galaxy s suite mais
voilà il ya encore des points
d'interrogation et c'est vraiment hyper
excitant 2010 est une année où la
téléphonie mobile va être tirée vers le
haut et bas du coup les prix aussi est
notre portefeuille tirés vers le bas
fatalement sait très bien que c'est
comme ça que ça marche regardons déjà
les grandes nouveautés et ce qu'ont
annoncé les nouvelles fonctions
l ip pour ce samsung galaxy s suit alors
déjà l'info elle vient pas de nulle part
elle vient pas de n'importe où à john un
site qui est très sérieux ces formes 15
caractéristiques révélée par une
nouvelle fuite
donc là effectivement on n'est plus dans
la rumeur on her des contacts qui sont
très très proches je dirais de la
réalisation et de la fabrication de la
conception même de samsung galaxy s suit
donc on est sur des sources qui sont
quand même très fiable qu'est ce qu'on
apprend dans force et qu'est ce qu'on
apprend dans ce nouvel article on
apprend que le samsung galaxy s suite
sera équipé d'un écran 6,2 pouces
également supérieur de 0 7 pouces par
rapport au galaxy s cette aide qu'il
remplace donc effectivement indique rend
un peu plus grand d'ailleurs point des
écrans si tu regardes vaches tactique
des sur la page youtube de samsung va
directement sortie de samsung tu verrais
que donne un aperçu
on demande aux chinois je dirais
d'ailleurs c'est marrant pour des
coréens du sud mais bon peu importe on a
perçu en ombres chinoises de ce que va
être le samsung galaxy ace suite et une
voix très très bien un ebook sur phone
un téléphone avec des légères courbure
sur le haut et sur le bas et un écran
complet qui va jusqu'à la bordure risque
haut sur les côtés avec un écran qui
sera forcément légèrement incurvé pour
qu'on n'est pas content et donc un écran
plus grand
qui va prendre quasiment la totalité de
ce téléphone forme nous annonce aussi un
changement de ratio indique que la
résolution des deux téléphones
augmentera à 2960 par deux mille 400
pixels et les deux modèles seront
équipés pour la première fois d'un écran
oled
donc on va vraiment tirer la résolution
est tirée la qualité de l'écran vers le
haut autre grande nouveauté on
l'annonçait déjà dans les rumeurs
concernant l'iphone 8
je pense que ça fait exactement la même
chose pour samsung pour son galaxy et
suit ce avec la touche home qui
disparaît au basta terminée ciao bye bye
un nouveau capteur de reconnaissance
d'iris fera partie d'un lot de six
capteurs le long de la bordure
supérieure de chacun des nouveaux galaxy
proximité lumière ambiante
iris émetteur ir l'aide caméra frontale
et récepteurs dont tu auras une tomme de
technologie une tonne de récepteurs une
pomme de capteurs qui seront basés tous
trop de ton téléphone normalement ici et
ce qui est plus intéressant on connaît
déjà
capteur de luminosité tu vois très bien
qu'on téléphone en cochant la lumière
ambiante a effectivement changé il va
être soit plus brillants soient moins
pour économiser sur tout pour pas trop
statique et l'oeil là par contre la
connaissance d'iris ça devrait être un
truc qui regrette juste top on espère
par contre que ce sera vraiment très
performant qui aura pas dire et des bugs
d'une personne à l'autre même si on sait
que les eris comme les empreintes
digitales sont vraiment des choses
uniques
il y en a pas deux y'a pas de copie donc
à moins qu'on t'enlève tournoi en balade
fournisseurs à 32 piraté son téléphone
chacun des téléphones possède quatre
modules de l'ariège le flash de
l'appareil photo en haut à gauche
le capteur de fréquence cardiaque en bas
à gauche l'appareil photo principale au
milieu et leucate d'empreintes digitales
à droite et la droite ce qui fait que
quand tu perds ton téléphone
non parce que lille en quarts 3 quand tu
te noies ton téléphone par l'arrière tu
auras en hausse très à droite comme ça
la reconnaissance d'empreinte digitale
sera pas comme sur les iphone a appuyé
devant pour le déverrouiller tu passes
ton téléphone qu'il tiendra comme ça et
avec ton doigt hop tu as pura et ça
pourra déverrouiller
c'est quand même pas compte ça veut dire
que quand tu nous tiens ils pensent
vraiment une position naturelle à la
potion de laquelle on le tient en règle
générale tu tiens et ça va déverrouiller
ce a fallu job tout seul on va pas
chercher je dirais une position de
l'inconfort même si effectivement le
fait d'appuyer là on n'est pas
particulièrement sur un inconfort en
tout cas toujours est il que ça permet
de dégager de la place de pleuvoir ce
gros boutons rome et de solutionner le
problème
environ ce bouton en leur ajoutant
derrière ce qui est hyper intelligent
sept coloris seront disponibles
or argent noir brillant noir mat bleus
orchidées et rose
reste à voir dans quelle pêche à la
version sera disponible bon le rose
l'orchidée pour moi je m'en fou noir mat
doit être toque noire brillante du déjà
vu
or argent bon c'est pareil c'est des
grands classiques on les colis notamment
avec les iphone donc on ne va pas
nécessairement plus besoin de ça mais
moi en tout cas le samsung est ce qu'il
demande vraiment
en noir mat ça doit être un petit côté
très élégant très sympa très chic très
côte est de l'île y avoir les deux
téléphones seront équipés d'un nouvel
appareil photo frontal de 8 négatif de 8
mégapixels et à l'arrière raconte on
regarde toujours le 2 12 mégapixels qui
fonctionne très bien
on sait d'ailleurs que samsung a une
qualité d'image qui est vraiment
irréprochable en terme de qualité photo
une vidéo ça fonctionne super bien
comme prévu le port micro usb et
remplacé par un port usb de type c ces
nouveaux standards un usb c'est un donc
que tu va le retrouver je dirais
quasiment partout un nouveau mode pc
donc ça c'est un peu la nouveauté un
nouveau mode pc sera activée lorsque le
téléphone sera placé dans un dock
spécial sûrement extra donc à acheter au
plus qui va encore augmenter la note qui
tu veux le full options je dirais puis
connecter un moniteur ou un téléviseur
créant un environnement similaire pour
l'utilisateur à celui d'un ordinateur de
bureau tu vois qu'on va vraiment vers la
fin des ordinateurs de bureau vers la
fin probablement pas des laptops
mais en tout cas tous les gros
ordinateurs moins de chercher de la
puissance on va vraiment vers la fin on
va vraiment sur des ordinateurs qui vont
être fan l'ex tous des choses comme ça
tu pourras même si son ordinateur
directement avec ce dock pourquoi pas
avoir un clavier au plus et le mettre
sur un moniteur pour pouvoir utiliser dj
comme un vrai ordinateur directement en
tout cas pour les applications qui
nécessitent pas trop de ressources en
eau notamment du traitement de texte à
la gestion de contacts de la gestion
d'agenda pour du professeur en tout cas
ça peut être bien ça peut éviter quand
on va se retrouver dans le bureau d'un
vin
un hôtel ou n'importe où pour pouvoir
bosser un petit peu pouvoir avoir un
moniteur un peu plus grand pour se poser
le regard est vide et toujours sur un
petit écran et au final bas de
s'arracher les yeux et d'une tour y
avoir de finir un budget de file job de
finir à 9 enfin je te base l'histoire
tout est si effectivement la nuit sanaa
d'avoir bon et je dis n'importe quoi
continuons alors les modèles vendus aux
etats-unis au japon et en chine seront
équipés d'un processeur snapdragon 835
tandis que les modèles vendus en europe
et dans le reste de l'asie surmonté d'un
professeur exynos 8 1895 de samsung bon
techniquement
moi je m'en fous j'y connais rien si tes
connaissances intéresse tant mieux
toujours utile tu vois là c'est parti je
dirais des infos qui ont fuité
les modèles coréens et chinois des
galaxies et suit les galaxy s ud plus
possède six gigant mémoire vive contre 4
gigas dans le reste du monde
les galaxy s 8 et esprit de plus seront
certainement mis à la vente le 21 avril
la donc ce nouveau téléphone devrait
vraiment rencontré un franc succès avec
plein de fonctionnalités avec
effectivement sur tout ce qui est
vraiment très très très impressionnant
c'est l'aspect graphique qui est
complètement revisitée avec surtout un
écran complètement utile est
complètement dégagé ce qui permet à sa
motion de réalité d'augmenter la taille
de son écran sans augmenter la taille de
son téléphone tu vas qu'au final les
nouveaux téléphones vont vraiment dans
le sens d'être un appel borderless plus
de bordures sur les côtés des écrans
incurvés donc au final on peut vraiment
optimisé son écran optimisé ce qu'on va
pouvoir en faire et avoir une plus
grande surface de contact pour le doigt
et faire encore plus de choses avec il
devrait aussi y avoir un nouvel
assistant alors ça je n'ai pas vu dans
forme je n'ai vu ailleurs il devrait y
avoir un nouvel assistant dédié
directement à ce téléphone qui
s'appellerait bigbee avec un bouton
dédié directement sur le téléphone
donc ça permettrait effectivement
d'avoir une nouvelle intelligence
artificielle uniquement pour les
téléphones samsung est un téléphone qui
sera présenté lors de la keynote du 29
mars prochain tu palais sur le site de
samsung si tu souhaites parce que tu vas
pouvoir je devrais te préinscrire de
préenregistrer faire partie des
premières personnes à avoir toutes les
informations sur téléphone un smartphone
qui devrait pouvoir être pré commande
quelques jours après il dit
avril est lancée directement le 29 avril
directement sur le marché
il ya une stratégie derrière tout ça si
tu veux c'est que si ce téléphone il
arrive à faire un buzz qui est un vrai
engouement
tous les gens et ça peut même faire
switcher des utilisateurs d'apple de
jean claude est déçu même switcher
dessus le précommander ça permettra de
couper un peu l'herbe sous le pied à
apple pour son iphone 10 si samsung
réussi son coup il devrait faire perdre
des parts de marché directement apple et
le se positionner en leader et récupérer
la position de leader mondial dans la
téléphonie mobile en tout cas toujours
utile c'est super intéressant quand on
s'intéresse à d'un petit peu plus près
parce que on comprend les différents
enjeux la gestion du calendrier est ce
que au final apple ne prend pas des
risques quand je dirais en gardant le
téléphone qui normalement devrait sortir
en septembre 2010 est alors que samsung
a vraiment pris les devants pour sortir
son galaxy un peu plus tôt avoir avoir
effectivement
est ce que les gens vont attendre de
voir ce que va lancer apple avant de
switcher directement sur la galaxy ace
lui est ce que les propositions de
samsung seront suffisamment forte pour
emmener des gens à switcher d' apple à
samsung
toujours est il que voilà on en saura
plus le 29 mars
restez connectés elles ne seront au
rendez vous pour vous en dire plus on
regardera ça directement cendres pour à
débriefer
en attendant tout ça et a tendance à
parenty veut plus tu me mets tout en
commentaire tu me dis ce que tu en
penses
parce que ça fait déjà un utilisateur
samsung est ce que tu es plutôt apple
plutôt samsung est ce que tu penses à
l'est sur le galaxy ensuite si oui est
ce que le prix normalement annoncé aux
alentours de 800 euros pour la suite et
900 euros pour le et suit plus est-ce
que ça va être un frein pour toi oui non
est ce que tu penses switcher sur un
iphone dixième édition qui devrait
normalement encore plus cher que le
samsung galaxy s suit donc voilà de
toute façon on pourra pas mettre de
l'argent partout on pourra pas avoir de
smartphones à moins d'être créée du cdh
à marigny téléphoniques ce qui est tout
cas n'est pas le cas de la plupart de
gens donc dis moi ce que t'en penses tu
me tout en commentaire n'hésite pas
regarder cette vidéo la khl aussi très
sympa abonne toi tant leurs six petits
gars très vite puis à bientôt
ciao